he's kind of always wanted a sense of
helping people it's
how he's always been so if he if there's
something he can do he'll try and do it
that's who he is as a person courtney
and chelsea coma knew their dad paul
yuri was an aid worker but neither knew
the 45 year old had traveled to ukraine
until they found out he'd been seized
and detained by russian forces
it might seem selfish for other people
but
i do feel a bit like why have you gone
and done this why why did our dad do it
because it wasn't it wasn't a big group
of them it was my dad and some other
people i can't even
put it in words
how angry i was when i found out
especially that it was captured as well
it just makes everything even worse
these are the last messages courtney had
from her dad before his phone was turned
off it's believed this is the day he was
captured you don't know what's happening
you don't know if he's safe
you you don't know where he is so
kind of more upset than anything it's
the feeling of being helpless there's
nothing you can do but you realize he's
been captured so that's the reason he's
not messaging back
since his capture a video of paul yuri
has appeared on russian tv in handcuffs
he says he wanted to visit ukraine
because he didn't believe uk media
coverage of the war his daughters
believe these were words said under
duress it was for them a horrendous
video to watch
not something we wanted to see but at
the same time we we're glad we're seeing
it because we know
he's okay that he's like yeah he's alive
and he's okay paul yuri was captured
alongside another british national 22
year old dylan healey it's believed
russia is accusing both men of being
mercenaries we fought the worst of
everything yeah because i think we have
to think of the worst because prepare
for it i don't think any time soon he'll
be home no i don't think so either so
we've just got her
so i coping for now until we realize
until we know anything more if he'll be
okay there if he's coming home or if
he's going back to ukraine as a presence
what we don't know
so we're preparing for the worst until
we know
but hopefully
yeah
until then messages like this one are
all they can send in the hope there
could soon be a reply
catherine of autopsy sky news in
manchester